alright hello everybody welcome back
glad you came back
today we will unveil the first tutorial
the first project is deep traffic code
named deep traffic where your task is to
solve the traffic problem using deep
reinforcement learning and I'll talk
about what's involved in designing a
network there how you submit your own
network how you participate in the
competition as I said the winner gets a
very special prize to be announced later
what is machine learning several types
they're supervised learning as I
mentioned yesterday that's what's meant
usually when you discuss about you talk
about machine learning and talk about it
successive supervised learning requires
a data set well you know the ground
truth you know the inputs and the
outputs and you provide that to a
machine learning algorithm in order to
learn the mapping between the inputs and
the outputs in such a way that you can
generalize to further examples in the
future
unsupervised learning is the other side
when you know absolutely nothing about
the outputs about the truth of the data
that you're working with all you get is
data and you have to find underlying
structure underlying representation of
the data that's meaningful for you to to
accomplish a certain task whatever that
is there's semi-supervised data or only
parts usually a very small amount is has
is labeled there's ground truth
available for just the small fraction of
it you think of images that are out
there on the internet and then you think
about image net a data set where every
image is labeled the size of that image
that data set is a tiny subset
of all the images on the available
online but that's the task we're dealing
with as human beings as people
interested in doing machine learning is
how to expand the size of that of the
part of our data that we know something
confidently about and reinforcement
learning sits somewhere in between it's
it's semi supervised learning where
there's an agent that has to exist in
the world and that agent knows the input
that the world provides but knows very
little about that world except through
occasional time delayed rewards this is
what it's like to be human that's what
life is about you don't know what's good
and bad you kind of have to just live it
and every once in a while you find out
that all that stuff you did last week
was pretty bad idea that's reinforcement
learning
that's semi-supervised in the sense that
only a small subset of the day that
comes with some ground truth some
certainty you have to then extract
knowledge from so first at the core of
anything that that works currently in
terms of a practically in the practical
sense there has to be some ground truth
there has to be some truth that we can
hold on to as we try to generalize and
that's supervised learning even as in
reinforcement learning the only thing we
can count on is that truth that comes in
a form of a reward
so the standard supervised learning
pipeline is you have some raw data the
inputs you have ground truth the labels
the output that matches to the input
then you run a certain any kind of
algorithm whether that's a neural
network or another people
processing algorithm that extracts the
features from that data set you can
think of a picture of a face that
algorithm could extract the nose the
eyes the corners of the eyes the pupil
or even lower level features in that
image after that we insert those
features into a into a model a machine
learning model will train that model
then we as we whatever that algorithm is
is it pass it through that training
process we then evaluate after we've
seen the exhibit this one particular
example how much better are we at other
tasks and as we repeat this loop the
model learns to perform better and
better at generalizing from the raw data
to the labels that we have and finally
you get to release that model into the
wild to actually do prediction on data
as never seen before that you don't know
about and the tasks there is to predict
the labels okay so neural network is
what this class is about it's one of the
machine learning algorithm that has
proven to be very successful and the
building block the computational
building block of a neural network is a
neuron a perceptron is a type of neuron
it's the original old school neuron
where the output is binary as 0 or 1
it's not real valued in the process the
perceptron goes through is it has
multiple inputs and a single output the
but each of the inputs have weights on
them shown here on the left that's point
seven point six one point four those
weights are applied to the inputs and a
perceptron the inputs are one or zero
binary and those weights are applied to
and then sum together a bias on each
neuron is then added on top and a
threshold there's a test whether that
sums value plus the bias is below or
above a threshold if it's above
threshold but this is the one for the
below a threshold the produces a zero
simple it's one of the only things we
understand about neural networks
confidently we can prove a lot of things
about this neuron for example what we
know is that a neuron can approximate a
approximate and they engage a NAND gate
is a logical operation logical function
that takes this input it has two inputs
a and B here on the dot on the diagram
on the left and the table
shows what that function is when the
inputs are zero zero one in any order
the output is the one otherwise it's a
zero the cool thing about a NAND gate is
that it's a universal gate that you can
build up any computer you have where you
phone in your pocket today can be built
out of just NAND gates so it's a it's a
functionally complete you could build
any logical function out of them if you
stack them together in arbitrary ways
the problem with NAND gates and
computers is they're built from the
bottom up you have to design these
circuits of NAND gates so the cool thing
here is the perceptron we can
earn this magical man gate we can learn
this function so let's go through what
how we can do that how a perceptron can
perform the NAND operation here's the
four examples if we put the weights of
negative 2 on the IMP on each of the
inputs and a bias of 3 on the neuron
then if we perform that same operation
of summing the weights times the input
plus the bias in the top-left we get
when the inputs are zero and there's
some to the bias we get a 3 that's a
that's a positive number which means the
output of a perceptron will be a 1 on
the top right when the input is a 0 and
a 1 that sum is still a positive number
again produces a 1 and so on but when
the inputs are both 1 then the output is
a negative 1 less than 0
so while this is simple it's really
important to think about it's it's a
sort of the one basic computational
truth you can hold on to as we talked
about some of the magical things neural
network can do because if you compare a
circuit of NAND gates and the circuit of
neurons the difference while a circuit
of neurons which is what we think of as
a neural network can perform the same
thing as the circuit of NAND gates what
it can also do is you can learn it can
learn the arbitrary logical functions
that as arbitrary circuit of NAND gates
can represent but it doesn't require the
human designer we can evolve if you will
so one of the key aspects here one of
the key drawbacks of perceptron is it's
not very smooth in its output as we
change the weight on the inputs and we
change the bias and we tweak it a little
bit it's very likely that when you get
it's very easy to make the neuron I'll
put a zero instead of a 1 a 1 instead of
a zero so when we start stacking many of
these together it's hard to control the
output of the thing as a whole now the
essential step that makes a neural
network work that a circular perceptron
doesn't is that the output is made
smooth it's made continuous with an
activation function and it's so instead
of using a step function like a
perceptron does shown there on the left
we use any kind of smooth function a
sigmoid where the output can change
gradually as you change the weight and
the bias and this is a basic but
critical step and so learning is
generally the process of adjusting those
weights gradually and seeing how it has
an effect on the rest of the network
you just keep tweaking blades here and
there and seeing how much closer you get
to the ground truth and if you get
farther away you just adjust the weights
in the opposite direction that's you
know networks in a nutshell there is
what we will mostly talk about today
it's feed-forward neural networks on the
left going from input to output
with no loops there is also these
amazing things called recurrent neural
networks they're amazing because they
have memory they have a memory of state
they remember the temporal dynamics of
the data that went through but the
painful thing is that they're really
hard to train today we'll talk about
feed full neural networks so let's look
at this example an example of stacking a
few a few of these neurons together
let's think of the task the basic tasks
now-famous using the classification of
numbers you have an image of a number
handwritten number and your task is
given that image to say what number is
in that image now what is an image an
image is the collection of pixels in
this case 28 by 28 pixels that's a total
of 784 numbers those numbers are from 0
to 255 and on the left of the network we
the size of that input
despite the diagram is 784 neurons
that's the input then comes the hidden
layer it's called the hidden layer
because it has it has no interaction
with the input or the output it is
simply a block use the it's at the core
of the computational power of neural
networks is the hidden layer it's tasked
with forming a representation of the
data in such a way that it maps from the
inputs to the outputs in this case there
are 15 neurons in the hidden layer
there is ten values on the output
corresponding to each of the numbers
there's several ways you could you can
build this kind of network and this is
what the magic of neural networks is you
can do in a lot of ways you only really
need four outputs to represent values
zero through nine but in practice it
seems that having ten outputs works
better and how do these work whenever
the input is a five the output neuron in
charge of the five gets really excited
and I'll put a value that's close to one
from zero to one close to one and then
the other one gets a output of value
hopefully that is close to zero and when
they don't we adjust the weights in such
a way that they get closer to zero and
closer to one depending on whether it's
the correct neuron associated with the
picture we'll talk about the details of
the training process more tomorrow when
it's more relevant but the what we've
discussed just now is the forward path
through the network it's the past when
you take the inputs apply the weight sum
them together add the bias produce the
output and check which of the outputs
produces the highest confidence of the
number then once those probabilities for
each of the numbers is provided we
determine the gradient that's used to
punish or reward the weights that
resulted in either the correct or the
incorrect decisions and that's called
back propagation we step backwards
through the network applying those
punishments or rewards because of the
smoothness of the activation functions
that is a mathematically efficient
operation that's where the GPIO GPUs
step in so for example of numbers the
ground truth
for number six looks like the following
in the slides Y of X equals to a 10
dimensional vector where only one of
them the the sixth value is a one the
rest are 0 that's the ground truth that
comes with the image the loss function
here the basic loss function is the
squared error Y of X is the ground truth
and a is the output of the neural
network resulting from the forward path
so when you input that number of a of a
6 and it outputs whatever it outputs
that's 8 a 10 dimensional vector and
it's summed over the inputs to produce
the squared error that's our loss
function the loss function the objective
function that's what's used to determine
how much to reward or punish the back
propagated weights throughout the
network and the basic operation of
optimizing that loss function of
minimizing that loss function it's done
with various variants of gradient
descent it's hopefully a somewhat smooth
function but it's a highly nonlinear
function this is why we can't prove much
about neural networks is it it's a
highly high dimensional highly nonlinear
function that's hopefully smooth enough
where the gradient descent can find its
way to at least a good solution and
there has to be some stochastic element
there that doesn't get that jumps around
to ensure that it doesn't get stuck in a
local minima of this very complex
function okay that's supervised learning
there's inputs
there's output ground truth it's our
comfort zone
we're pretty confident we know what's
going on all you have to do is if you
have this data set you train and you
train a network on that data set and you
can evaluate it you can write a paper
and try to beat a previous paper it's
great the problem is when you then use
that neural network to create an
intelligent system that you put out
there in the world and now that system
no longer is working with your data set
it has to exist in this world that
doesn't matter that may be very
different from the ground truth so the
takeaway from supervised learning is
that you know networks the great
memorization but in a sort of
philosophical way they might not be
great at generalizing at reasoning
beyond the specific flavor of data set
that they were trained on the hope for
reinforcement learning is that we can
extend the knowledge we gained in the
supervised way to the huge world outside
where we don't have the ground truth of
how to act of what does how good a
certain state is or how bad a certain
state is this is a kind of brute force
reasoning and I'll talk about kind of
what I mean there but it feels like it's
close to the reasoning as opposed to
memorization that's a good way to think
of supervised learning as memorization
you're just studying for an exam and as
many of you know that doesn't mean
you're going to be successful in life
just because you get an A and so a
reinforcement learning agent or just any
agent a human being or any machine
existing in this world can operate in
the following way from the perspective
of the age it it can execute an action
it can receive an observation resulting
from that action in a form of a new
state
and it can receive a reward or
punishment you can break down every are
you can it can break down our existence
in this way simplistic view but it's a
convenient one on the computational side
and from the environment side the
environment receives the action emits
the observations so your action changes
the world therefore that world has to
change and then tell you about it and
give you a reward or a punishment for it
so let's look at again one of the most
fascinating things I'll try to convey
why this is fascinating a little bit
later on is the work of deep mind on
Atari this is atari breakout a game
where a paddle has to move around that's
the world that's existing in it's a
paddle the agent of the paddle and
there's a bouncing ball and you trying
to move your actions the right move
right move left and so you try to move
in such a way that the ball doesn't get
passed here and so here is a human level
performance of that agent and so what
does this paddle have to do that's
operating this environment that's the
act move left move right each action
changes the state of the world that she
may seem obvious but moving right
changes visually the state of the world
in fact what we're watching now on the
slide is the world changing before your
eyes so this little guy and it gets
rewards or punishments rewards it gets
in the form of points they're racking up
points on the top-left of the of the
video and then when the ball gets past
the paddle it gets punished
by dying quote-unquote and that's the
number of lies there is left going from
five to four to three down to zero and
so the goal is to select at any one
moment the action that maximizes future
award without any knowledge of what a
reward is in a greater sense of the word
all you have is an instantaneous reward
or punishment instantaneous response to
the world to your actions and this can
be modeled as a Markov decision process
Markov decision process is a
mathematically convenient construct it
has no memory all you get is you have a
state that you're currently in you
perform an action you get a reward and
you find yourself in a new state and
that repeats over and over you start you
from state 0 you go to state 1 you once
again repeat in action get a reward go
to the next state okay that's the
formulation that we're operating in when
you're in a certain state you have no
memory of what happened two states ago
everything is operating on the
instantaneous instantaneously and so
what are the major components of a
reinforcement learning agent there's a
policy that's that's the agent the
function of broadly defined of an agent
behavior that means that includes the
knowledge of how for any given state
what is an action that I will take with
some probability value function is how
good each state and action are in any
particular state and there's a model now
this is a little subtle thing that is
actually the biggest problem with
everything you'll see today is the model
is how we represent
the environment and we'll see today some
amazing things that neural networks can
achieve on a relatively simplistic model
of the world and the question whether
that model can extend to the real world
where human lives are at stake in the
case of driving so let's look at the
simplistic world a robot in a room he
start at the bottom left your goal is to
get to the top right your possible
actions are going up down left and right
now this world could be deterministic
which means when you take when you go up
you actually go up or it could be
non-deterministic as human life is it's
when you go up sometimes you go right so
in this case if you choose to go up you
move up 80% of the time you move left
10% of the time and move right 10% of
the time
and when you get to the top right you
get a reward of +1 then you get to the
second block from that for 2 you get
negative 1 you get punished and every
time you take a step you get a slight
punishment of point 0 4 ok so question
is if you start at the bottom left is
this a good solution is this a good
policy by which you exist in the world
and it is if the world is deterministic
if whenever you choose to go up you go
up I mean I urge you to go right you go
right but if the actions are stochastic
that's not the case in what I described
previously with point 8 up and
probability of 0.1 going left and right
this is the optimal policy now if we
punished every single step with a
negative 2 as opposed to negative
1:04 so every time you take a step it
hurts you're going to try to get to a a
positive block as quickly as possible
and that's what this policy says I'll
walk through a negative one if I have to
as long as I get stopped getting a
negative 2 now it's the reward for each
step is a negative 0.1 you might choose
to go around that negative one block a
slight detour to avoid the pain and then
you might take an even longer detour as
the reward for each step goes up or the
punishment goes down I guess and then
and then it's the there's a actual
positive reward for every step you take
then you'll never you'll avoid going to
your finish line
you'll just wander the world we saw that
would be Coast Racer yesterday the the
boat that chose not to finish the race
because it was having too much fun
getting points in the middle so let's
look at the world that this agent is
operating in is the value function that
value function depends on a reward the
word that comes in the future and that
reward is discounted because the world
is stochastic we don't we can't expect
the reward to come along to us in the
way that we hope it does based on the
policy based on the way we choose to act
and so there's a gamma there that over
time as the reward is farther and
farther into the future discount that
rewards
diminishes the impact of that future
award in your evaluation of the current
state and so your goal is to develop a
strategy that maximizes the discounted
future award this sum this discounted
sum and reinforcement learning there's a
lot of approaches for coming up with a
good policy a near optimal an optimal
policy there's a lot of fun math there
you could try to construct a model that
optimizes some estimate of this world
you can try in a monte carlo way to just
simulate that world and see how it
unrolled and as it unrolls you try to
compute the optimal policy or what we'll
talk about today is Q learning it's an
off policy approach where the policy is
estimated as we go along the policy is
represented as a Q function the Q
function shown there on the left is I
apologize for the equations
I lied there'll be some equations the
the input to the Q function is a state
at time T ft and action you choose to
take and that state a T and your goal is
in that state to choose an action which
maximizes the reward in the next step
and what Q learning does and I'll
describe the process is its able to
approximate through experience the
optimal Q function the optimal function
that tells you how to act in any state
of the world you just have to live it
you have to simulate this world you have
to move about it you have to explore in
order to see every possible state try
every different action get rewarded get
punished and figure out what is the
optimal thing to do that's done using
the bellman equation on the left the
output is the new state the estimate the
Q function estimate of the new state for
new action and that's this is the update
rule at the core of Q learning you take
the estimate the old estimate and add
based on the learning rate alpha from 0
to 1 they update the evaluation of that
state based on your new reward that you
received at that time so you've arrived
in a certain state s T you try to do an
action and then you got a certain reward
and you update your estimate of that
state and action pair based on this rule
when the learning rate is zero you don't
learn on alpha is zero you never change
your worldview based on the new new
incoming evidence when alpha is 1 you
every time change your evaluation your
world evaluation based on the new
evidence and that's the key ingredient
to reinforcement learning first you
explore then you exploit first you
explore in a non greedy way and then you
get greedy you figure out what's good
for you and you keep doing it so if you
want to learn an Atari game first you
try every single action every state you
screw up get punished get rewarded and
eventually you figure out what's
actually the right thing to do and you
just keep doing it and that's how you
win against the greatest world of the
greatest human players in the world in a
game of gold for example as we'll talk
about and the way you do that is you
have an epsilon greedy policy that over
time with a probability of 1 minus
epsilon you perform an optimal greedy
action with a probability of epsilon you
perform a random action random action
being Explorer and so as epsilon goes
down from one to zero there's four or
less and less so the algorithm here is
really simple on the bottom of the slide
there that's the algorithm version the
pseudocode version of the equation the
bellman equation update you initialize
your estimate of state action pairs
arbitrarily a random number this is an
important point when you start playing
or living or doing whatever you're doing
in whatever you're doing with
reinforcement learning or driving you
have no preconceived notion of what's
good and bad its random or however you
choose to initialize it and the fact
that it learns that anything is amazing
hey I want you to remember that that's
one of the amazing things about the key
learning at all and then the deep neural
network version of Q learning the
algorithm repeats the following step you
step into the world observe an initial
state you select an action eight so that
action if you're exploring will be a
random action if you're greedily
pursuing the best action you can you'll
be the action that maximizes the Q
function you observe a reward after you
take two action and a new state that you
find yourself in and then you update
your estimate
of the previous state you are in having
given taken that action using that
bellman equation update and repeat this
over and over so they're on the bottom
of the slide is a summary of life yep
see the Q function yes yes yeah it's a
single the question was is the Q
function a single value and yes it's
it's just a single continuous value
so the question was how do you model the
world
so the way you model so let's start it's
very simplistic world of Atari paddle
you think you model it as a paddle that
can move left and right and there's some
blocks and you model the physics of the
the ball that requires a lot of expert
knowledge in that particular game so you
sit there handcrafting this model that's
hard to do even for simplistic game the
other model you could take is looking at
this world in the way that humans do
visually so take the model in as a set
of pixels just the model is all the
pixels of the world you know nothing
about paddles or balls or physics or
colors and points they're just pixels
come in that seems like a ridiculous
model of the world but it seems to work
for Atari it seems to work for human
beings when you're born you see there's
light coming into your eyes and you
don't have any as far as far as we know
you don't come with an instruction and
you're born you know there's people in
the world and there is good guys and bad
guys and it's just how you walk no all
you get is light sound and the other
sensors and and you get to learn about
the every single thing you think of as
the way you model the world is a learned
representation and we'll talk about how
a neural network does that it learns to
represent the world but if we have to
hand model the world it's an impossible
task it's that that's the question if we
have to hand model the world then that
world better be a simplistic one yeah
that's a great question so the question
was what is the robustness of this model
it's the way you represent the world is
it all even slightly different
from the way you thought that world is
that's not that well study as far as I'm
aware you I mean it's it's already
amazingly if you construct if you have a
certain input of the world if you have a
certain model of the world you can learn
anything is already amazing the question
is and it's important one is we'll talk
a little bit about it not about the
world model but the reward function if
the reward function is slightly
different the real reward function of
life or driving or a Coast Runner is
different than what you expected it to
be what's the what's the negative there
yes it's a it could be huge so there's
another question or no I mean yep sorry
can you ask that again yes you can
change it over so the question was do
you change the Alpha value over time you
certainly should change the Alpha value
over time yeah oh so the question was
what is the the complex interplay of the
epsilon function with a few learning
update
that's 100% fine-tuned and tuned to the
particular learning problem so you
certainly want to the more complex the
larger the number of states in the world
and the larger the number of actions the
longer you have to wait before you
decrease that salon to zero but you have
to play with it and it's one of the
parameters you have to play with
unfortunately and there's quite a few of
them which is why you can't just drop a
reinforcement learning agent into the
world
oh the effect in essence no no it's just
a coin flip and if it's that epsilon 2.5
half the time you're going to take a
random action so it's no there's no
specific it's not like you'll take the
best action and then with some
probability take the second bass and so
on I mean you could certainly do that
but in the simple formulation that works
if you just take a random action because
you don't want to have a preconceived
notion of what a good action to try when
you're exploring the whole point is you
try crazy stuff if it's a simulation
okay so good question
so representation matters this is the
question about how we represent the
world so we can think of this world of
breakup for example of this Atari game
as a paddle that moves left and right
and the exact position of the different
things you can hit construct this
complex model this expert driven model
that has to fine-tune it to this
particular problem but in practice the
more complex this model gets the worse
that development equation update that
valve is trying to construct a cube
function for every single combination of
state and actions becomes too difficult
because that function is too sparse and
huge so if you think of because of
looking at this world in a general way
and the way human beings would is a
collection of pixels visually if you
just take in a pixel this game is a
collection of eighty-four by eighty four
pixels an image an RGB image and then
you look at not just the current image
but look at the temporal trajectory of
those images so like if there's a ball
movie you want to know about that
movement so you look at four images so
currently image and three images back
and say they're grayscale with 256 a
grey levels
that's size of the cue table that the
q-value function has to learn is
whatever that number is but it's
certainly larger than the number of
atoms in the universe that's a large
number so
so you have to run the simulation long
enough to touch at least a few times the
most of the states in that queue table
so as you know a mosque says you may
need to run you know we live in a
simulation you may run have to run
another universe justice - to compute D
the cube function in this case so that's
where deep learning substance is instead
of modeling the world as a cue table you
estimate you try to learn that function
and so the takeaway from supervised
learning if you remember that it's good
at memorizing will go to memorizing data
the hope for reinforcement learning with
a cue cue learning is that we can extend
the occasional rewards we get to
generalize over the operation the
actions you take in that world leading
up to the rewards and the hope for deep
learning is that we can move this
reinforcement learning system into a
world that doesn't need to be they can
be defined arbitrarily can include all
the pixels of an Atari game can include
all the pixels sent by drone or a robot
or car but still it needs a formalized
definition of that world which is much
easier to do when you're able to take in
sensors like an image so ddq learning
the deep version so instead of learning
a cute table cue function we try and
estimating that q prime we try to learn
it using machine learning it tries to
learn some parameters this huge complex
function
we try to learn it and the way we do
that is we have a neural network the
same kind of showed that learns a
numbers to map from an image to a
classification of that image into a
number the same kind of network is used
to take in a state and action and
produce a Q value now here's the amazing
thing that without knowing anything in
the beginning as I said with a Q table
it's initialized randomly the Q function
so this deep network knows nothing in
the beginning all it knows is in the
simulated world the rewards you get for
a particular game so you have to play
time and time again and see the the
rewards you get for every single
iteration of the game but in the
beginning it knows nothing and it's able
to learn to play better than human
beings this is a deep mind paper playing
Atari with deep reinforcement learning
from 2013 so it's one of the key things
that got everybody excited about the
role of deep learning and artificial
intelligence is that using a common real
Network which I'll talk about tomorrow
but it's a it's a vanilla network like
any other like I talked about earlier
today just a regular network that takes
the raw pixels as I said and estimates
that Q function from the raw pixels is
able to play at many of those games
better than a human being and the lost
function that I mentioned previously so
again very vanilla lost function very
simple objective function the first one
you'll probably implement we have a
tutorial in tensorflow squared error so
we take this bellman equation
we're the estimate is Q the Q function
estimate of state and action is the
maximum reward you get for taking any of
the actions that takes you to any of the
future states and you try to take that
action observe the results of that
action and if the target is different
that your learned target you learned
what the function is learned is the
expected reward in that case it's
different than what you actually got you
adjust it your adjust the weights in the
network and this is exactly the process
by which we learn how to exist in this
pixel world so you're mapping States and
actions to a Q value the algorithm is as
follows this is how we train it we're
given a transition s current state
action taken in that state are the
rewards you get and s prime is what you
the state you find yourself in and so we
replace the basic update rule in the
previous pseudocode by taking a forward
pass through the network given that s
state we look at what the predicted Q
value is of that action we then do
another forward pass through that
network and see what we actually get and
then if we're totally off we punish we
back propagate the weights in a way that
next time we'll make less of that
mistake and you repeat this process and
this is a you're playing your this is a
simulation you're learning against
yourself
and again the same rule applies here
exploration versus exploitation you
start off with an epsilon of zero or one
you you're mostly exploring and then you
move towards an epsilon of zero and with
Atari breakout this is the deep mind
paper result is training epochs and the
x axis on the y axis is the average
action value and the average reward per
episode I'll show why it's kind of an
amazing result but it's messy because
there's a lot of tricks involved so it's
not just putting in a bunch of pixels of
a game and getting an agent that knows
how to win at that game there's a lot of
pre-processing
and playing with the data required so
which is unfortunate because the truth
is messier than the hope but one of the
critical tricks needed is called
experience replay so as opposed to
letting an agent so you're learning this
big Network that learn that tries to
build a model of what's good to do in
the world and what's not and you're
learning as you go so with experience
replay you're keeping a track of all the
things you did and ever ends every once
in a while you look back into your
memory and pull out some of those old
experiences the old good old times and
train on those again as opposed to
letting the agent run itself into some
local Optima where it tries to learn
very subtle aspects of the game that
actually in the global sense doesn't get
you farther to winning the game very
much likewise so here's the algorithm
deep cue learning algorithm
Shido code we initialize the replay
memory again there's this little trick
that's required it's keeping a track of
stuff that's happened in the past
we initialize the action value function
queue with random weights and observe
initial state again same thing select an
action with a probability Epsilon
Explorer otherwise she's the best one
based on the estimate provided by the
neural network and then carry out the
action observe the reward and store that
experience in the replay memory and then
sample random transition from replay
memory so with a certain probability you
bring to those old times back to get
yourself out of the local minima and
then you train the cure at the q network
using the the difference between your
what you actually got in your estimate
you repeat this process over and over so
here's what you can do after ten minutes
of training on the left so that's very
little training what you get is a paddle
that learned hardly anything and it just
keeps dying if you look at it goes from
5 to 4 to 3 to 2 to 1
those are the number of lives left then
after 2 hours of training on a single
GPU it learns to when it wouldn't you
know not die rack up points and learns
to avoid the balls from passing passing
the paddle which is great that's human
level performance really better than
some humans you know but it still dies
sometimes so it's very human level and
then after 4 hours it does something
really amazing it figures out how to win
at the game in a very lazy way which is
drill a hole through the blocks up to
the top and get the ball stuck up there
and then it does all the hard work for
you that minimizes the probability of
the ball getting past your paddle
it's just stuck in the in the in the
blocks up top so it that might be
something that you wouldn't even figure
out to do yourself and that's an aid to
sort of pause here to to clearly explain
what's happening the input to this
algorithm is just the pixels of the game
it's the same thing that human beings
take in when they take the visual
perception and it's able to learn under
this constrained definition of what is
the reward and a punishment it's able to
learn to get a high reward that's
general artificial intelligence a very
small example of it but its general its
general purpose it knows nothing about
games and knows nothing about paddles or
physics it's just taken three input of
the game and they've did the same thing
for a bunch of different games in Atari
and what's shown here in this plot on
the x axis and is a bunch of different
games from Atari and on the y axis is a
percentile where a hundred percent is
about the best that human beings can do
meaning it's the score that human beings
would get so everything about there in
the middle everything to the left of
that is far exceeding human level
performance and below that is on par or
worse than human level performance so
you can learn all so many boxing pinball
all of these games and it doesn't know
anything about any of the individual
games it's just taking in pixels it's
just as if you put a human being beside
behind any of these games and ask them
to learn to beat beat the game and then
been a lot of improvements in this
algorithm recently yes question yep nope
there's no so the question was do they
customize the model for game for a
particular game and no the point you
could of course but the point is it
doesn't need to be customized for the
game but but the important thing is that
it's still only on Atari games right so
the question whether this is
transferable to driving perhaps not
right you play the game what you do but
not you don't have to
well yeah you play one step of the game
so you take action in a state and then
you observe that so you have the
simulation I mean that's really that's
one of the biggest problems here is you
require the simulation to in order to
get the ground truth so that's a great
question and or a comment the comment
was that for a lot of these situations
the reward function might not change at
all depending on your actions the warts
are really most of the time delayed 10
20 30 steps down the line which is why
it is amazing that this works at all
that it's learning it's learning locally
and through that process of simulation
of hundreds of thousand five runs to the
game it's able to learn what to do now
such that I get a reward later
it's a if you just pause look at the
math of it it's very simple math and
look at the result it's incredible
so there's a lot of improvements this
one called the general reinforcement
learning architecture or gorilla the
cool thing about this in the simulated
world at least is that you can run deep
reinforcement learning and distributive
way you could do both the simulation in
distributer way you could do the
learning in the distributive way you can
you can generate experiences which is
what this kind of diagram shows you can
either from human beings or from
simulation so for example the way that
the way that alphago the deep mind team
is beat the game of go is they they
learn from both expert games and by
playing itself so you can do this in a
distributed way and you could do the
learning a distributed way so you can
scale and in this particular case the
gorilla has achieved a better result
than the DQ on network that's part of
their nature paper okay so let me now
get to driving for a second here where
where does reinforcement learning where
reinforcement learning could step in and
help so this is back to the open
question I asked yesterday it's driving
closer to chess or to everyday
conversation chess
meaning it can be formalized in a
simplistic way and it we could think
about it as an obstacle avoidance
problem and once the obstacle avoidance
is solved you just navigate that
constrained space you choose to move
left it's used to move right in a lane
you choose to speed up or slow down well
if it's a game like chess which we'll
assume for today as opposed to for
tomorrow for today we're going to go
with the one on the left and we're going
to look at deep traffic
here's this game or simulation where the
goal is to achieve the highest average
speed you can on this seven lane highway
full of cars and so as a side note for
students the requirement is they have to
follow the tutorial that I'll present a
link for at the end of this presentation
and what they have to do is achieve a
speed build a network that achieves a
speed of 65 miles an hour or higher
there is a leaderboard and you get to
submit the model you come up with with a
simple click of a button so all of this
runs in the browser
there's also another amazing thing and
then you immediately or relatively so
make your way up the leaderboard so
let's look let's zoom in what is this
what is this world two dimensional world
of traffic is what does it look like for
the intelligence system we discretize
that world into a grid showing here on
the left that's the representation of
the state there are seven lanes and
every single Lane is broken up into
blocks spatially and if there's a car in
that block the length of a car is about
three blocks three of those grid blocks
then that greatest scene is occupied and
then the red car is you that's the thing
that's running in the intelligent agent
there's on the left is the current speed
of the red car actually says MIT on top
and then you also have a count of how
many cars you passed and if your network
sucks and that number is going to get to
be negative
you can also change with a drop-down on
the simulation speed from normal on the
left too fast on the right so normal is
so you know the fast speeds of the
replay of the simulation the one on the
left normal it feels a little more like
real driving the there's a drop down for
different display options
the default is none in terms of stuff
you show on the road
then there is the learning input which
is the while this whole space is
discretized you can choose what your car
sees and that's you can choose how far
head of C's behind how far to the left
and right it sees and so by choosing the
learning input to visualize learning it
but you get to see what you set that
input to be then there is the safety
system this is a system that protects
you from yourself the way we've made
this game is that it operates under
something similar if you have some
intelligence if you drive and you have
adaptive cruise control in your car it
operates in the same way it when it gets
close to the car in front it slows down
for you and it doesn't let you run the
car to the left of you to the right of
you off the road so constrains the
movement capabilities of your car in
such a way that you don't hit anybody
because then it would have to simulate
collisions and that would just be a mess
so it protects you from that and so you
can choose to visualize that quote
unquote safety system with the
visualization box and then you can also
choose to visualize the full map this is
the full occupancy map that you get if
you would like to provide input to the
network
now that input for every single grid
that it's a number it's not just a zero
one whether there's a car in there
it's the maximum speed limit which is 80
miles per hour so don't go don't get
crazy 80 miles an hour's of speed limit
that block when it's empty is set to the
85 miles 80 miles an hour and when it's
occupied it's set to the number that the
speed of the car and then the blocks
that you the red car is occupying it's
said to the number to a very large
number of much higher than the speed
limit so safety system here shown in red
are the parts of the grid that are not
that your car can't move into question
[Music]
what's that yep yes yes the question was
what was the third option I just
mentioned and it's you the red car
itself give yourself the blocks
underneath that car are set to a really
high number it's a way for the algorithm
to know for the learning algorithm to
know that this these blocks are special
so safety system shows red here if the
car can't move into those blocks so any
in terms of when it lights up red it
means the car can't speed up anymore in
front of it and when the blocks to the
left it to the right light up with red
that means you can't change lanes to the
left or right on the right of the slide
you're free to go for you to do whatever
you want that's what that indicates
there's all the blocks are yellow safety
system says you're free to choose any of
the five actions and the five actions
our move left move right stay in place
accelerate or slow down and those
actions are given its input that action
is that's what's produced by the what's
called here the brain the brain takes in
the current state is input the last
reward and produces and to end learn
uses out a reward to train the network
to backward function their back
propagation and then ask the brain given
the current state to give it the next
action with a forward pass the forward
function you don't need to know the
operation of this function in particular
this is not something you need to worry
about but you can if you want you can
customize this learning step there is by
the way what I'm describing now there's
there's just a few lines of code right
there in the browser that you can change
it immediately well the press of a
button changes the simulation or the
design of the network you don't need to
have any special hardware you need to do
anything special and the tutorial
cleanly outlines exactly all of these
steps but it's kind of amazing that you
can design a deep neural network that's
part of the reinforcement learning
agents so it's a deep Q learning agent
right there in the browser so you can
choose the lane side variable which
controls how many lanes to the side you
see so when that value is zero you only
look forward when that value is one you
have one lane to the left one value to
the right really the lane the radius of
your perception system patches ahead is
how far ahead you look patches behind us
how far behind you look and so for
example here the lane side equals two
that means it looks two to the left two
to the right
obviously if two to the right is offroad
it provides a value of zero in those
blocks if we set the patches behind to
be ten it looks ten patches back behind
starting at the one patch back it's
starting from the front of the car the
scoring for the evaluation for the
competition is your average speed over a
predefined period of time and so the
method we do we use to collect that
speed as we rerun the agent ten runs the
ball thirty simulated minutes of game
each and takes a median speed of the ten
runs that's the score this is done
server-side and so given that we've
gotten some for this for this code
recently gotten some publicity online
unfortunately this might be a dangerous
thing to say is no cheating possible but
because it's done server-side and we did
the JavaScript and it runs in the
browser it's hopefully a sandbox so we
can't do anything tricky but we dare you
to try you can try it locally to get an
estimate and now there's a button that
says evaluate and it gives you a score
right back of how well you're doing with
into the current Network that button is
start evaluation run you press the
button it does the progress bar and it
gives you the hour speed you can the
there's a code box where you modify all
the variables I mentioned and the
tutorial describes this in detail and
then once you're ready you modify a few
things you can press apply code it
restarts it kills all the training that
you've done up to this point or resets
it and starts the training again so say
often and there's a Save button so the
training is done a separate thread in
web workers which are exciting things
that allow you to allow JavaScript to
run amazingly in you know you know on
multiple CPU cores in a parallel way so
the simulation that scores this or the
outside the training is done
a lot faster than real time a thousand
frames a second a thousand movement
steps a second this is all in JavaScript
and the net state gets shipped to the
main simulation from time to time as the
training goes on so all you have to do
is press run training and it trains and
the car behaves better over time maybe
I'll actually show it in the browser to
let's see for work well is it going to
mess up I'm good why is it being weird
what can possibly go wrong
so here's the game when it starts this
is running live in the browser
artificial intelligence
ladies and gentlemen in the browser a
neural network so currently it's not
very good it's driving a 2 miles an hour
and watching everybody pass so what's
being shown live is the lost function
which is pretty poor so in order to
train like it says thousand frames a
second you just press the run training
button and pretty quickly learns based
on the network you specify in the code
box how to and based on the input and
all the things that I mentioned training
finished it learns how to do a little
better we on purpose put in the network
that's not very good in there so right
now it won't on average be doing that
well but it does better than standing
there in place and then you can do the
start evaluation run to simulate then
that work much faster than real time to
see how well it does this is a similar
evaluation step that we take when
determining where you stand on the
leaderboard the current current average
speed in that 10 run simulation is 56
point five six miles per hour
now I may be logged in maybe not if
you're logged in you click submit your
code if you're not logged in it says
you're not logged in please log in to
submit your code and then all you have
to do is log in watch the most flawless
demo in my life and then you press the
mid model again and success oh man
thank you for your submission and so now
my submission is entered as Lex and the
leaderboard of my fifty six point five
six or whatever it was
so I dare all of you to try to beat that
so - as you play around with stuff if
you want to save the code you could do
so by pressing the Save code button that
saves the configure the various
JavaScript configurations and that saves
the network layout to file and then you
can load from file as well a danger it
overwrites the code for you and you
press the submit button to submit the
model to competition make sure that you
train the network we don't train it for
you you bring us you submit a model and
you have to press train and it gets
evaluated within time it answers a queue
to get evaluated this is public-facing
so the queue can grow pretty big and it
goes to that queue evaluates it and then
depending on where you stand you get
added to the leaderboard showing the top
ten entries you can resubmit often and
only the highest score counts okay
we're using we're using code now
implementation of neural networks done
in just JavaScript by andrey karpati
from stanford now open ai
ComNet jf is the library and what's
being visualized there it's also being
visualized in the game is the inputs to
the network in this case it's 135 inputs
so you can you can also specify not just
the not just the how far head behind you
see in to the left and to the right you
can specify how far back in time you
look as well and so what's visualized
there is the input to the network 135
and you're on
and then the output regression similar
to the kind of output we saw with
numbers where there's ten outputs saying
if it's a zero one through a nine here
the output is one of the five actions
left right stay in place speed up or
slow down the combat GF settings is you
can select a number of inputs if you
want to mess with this stuff this is all
the stuff you don't need to mess with
because we already give you the
variables of lane side and patches ahead
and so on you can select the number of
actions the temporal window and the
network's size so the the network
definition here is the this is the input
the size of the input again all this is
in the tutorial just to give you a
little outline there is a the first
fully connected layer has ten neurons
with rail you activation functions the
same kind of smooth function that we
talked the ball before and the
regression layer for the output and
there's a bunch of other messy options
that you can play with T there but those
aren't the ones I mentioned before it's
really the important one is selecting
the number of layers the size of those
layers you get to build your own very
neural network that dries and the actual
learning is done with a backward
propagation and then the that returns
the action by doing a forward pass of
the network in case you're interested in
this kind of stuff there is an amazingly
cool code editor that's the monocle
editor that it just works it does some
auto completion so you get to play with
it makes everything very convenient
terms of code editing a lot of this
visualization of the game at the end or
the simulation and the simulation we'll
talk about tomorrow is done in in the
browser using HTML
five canvas so here is a simple
specification of a blue box with canvas
and this is very efficient and easy to
work with and the thing that a lot of us
are excited about a very subtle one but
that you can not just run so with the v8
engine javascript has become super fast
you can you could train your own
networks in the browser that's already
amazing and then with web workers as
long as you have chrome a modern browser
is you can run multiple processes in
separate threads so we could do a lot of
stuff you can do visualization
separately and you can train the
separate threads very cool okay so the
tutorial it's cars that mit.edu in deep
traffic we won't put these links on the
website for a little bit because we got
put on the front page of hacker news
which we don't want those to leak out
especially with the claims that you
can't cheat and while it's pretty
efficient in terms of running tests so
everything is running on your machine
client side it's still you have to pull
some images here and pull some of the
code so the tutorial is on cars at MIT
tidy you slash deep traffic and the
simulation is deep traffic jf so cars
that MIT I use flash deep traffic jf I
encourage you to go there play with a
network submit your code and win the
very special prize it is a pretty cool
one but we're still working on it
it's not there is a prize I swear all
right so let's let's take a pause and
think about what we talked about today
so the very best of deep reinforcement
learning is the most exciting
accomplishment I think is one
the game when I first started as a
freshman took intro to artificial
intelligence it was said that it's the
game that's impossible
for machines to beat because of the
combinatorial complexity is just a sheer
number of options it's so much more
complex than chess and so the most
amazing accomplishment of deep
reinforcement learning to me is the
design of alphago when for the first
time the world champion and go was
beaten by deep minds alphago and the way
they did it and this is I think very
relevant to driving if you start by
creating first in a supervised way
training a policy network so you take
expert games to construct a network
first so you look you don't play against
yourself the agent of the play gets
itself but they learn from experts so
there's some human ground truth this
human ground truth represents reality so
for drying this is important level well
we're starting to get a lot of data or
video of drivers is being recorded so we
can learn on that data before we then
run the agents through a simulation
where it learns much larger magnitudes
of data sets for simulation and they did
just that now as a reminder that when
you let an agent drive itself this is
probably one favorite videos a long time
but I just recently saw a second just
watch this for hours but it's a reminder
that you can't you can't trust your
first estimates of a reward function to
be those that are safe and productive
for our society when
you're talking about an intelligence
system that gets to operate in the real
world this is just it's clear of a
reminder of that if there is so again
all the references are available online
for this for these slides we'll put up
the slides I imagine you might have if
you want to come down and talk to us for
questions for the either docker or
JavaScript question it's so the question
was what is the visualization you're
seeing in deep traffic you're seeing a
car move about how is it moving it's
moving based on the latest maps as a
network you trained so it's just
visualizing for you just for fun the
network you trained most recently okay
so if people have questions stick around
afterwards just details on docker and
and yes you want to do it offline